si je vous dis contraception vous allez
me dire pilule stérilet vous allez
peut-être me dire spermicide implant
patch
bref vous allez me parler de
contraception féminine et pourtant la
contraception masculine
ça existe aussi on va y aller crescendo
du plus connu au plus obscur et on
commence tout de suite avec le
préservatif le préservatif masculin
donc c'est à dire le préservatif externe
à vrai dire vous y avait sûrement pensé
tout seul parce que c'est de loin le
plus connu et le plus utilisé des moyens
de contraception masculine pourra dire
le seul moyen de contraception masculine
utilisé en france il ya des bonnes
raisons à ça déjà ça marche bien et il
n'y a pas d'effets secondaires
à part si on est allergique mais surtout
il protège aussi contre les infections
sexuellement transmissibles donc c'est
gagnant gagnant sur le préservatif a pas
besoin d'en dire beaucoup plus sain
c'est la tête de gondole c'est la star
incontestée des moyens de contraception
masculine
on va plutôt passer au challenger le
coïtus interruptus alors pour ce combat
fait latin ça veut dire coït interrompu
et déjà la première impression ces deux
mots la côte à côte
ça c'est le moyen rêvé on appelle ça
aussi la méthode du retrait là c'est
pareil c'était un petit peu opérations
bancaires ou défaite militaire
ça fait envie ça consiste pour l'homme à
se retirer avant l'éjaculation ça
al'avantage d'être une méthode naturelle
est gratuite et puis bon pas
d'éjaculation pas de fécondation
implacable comme logique donc super
efficace mais dans les faits il ya de
risques d'abord celui de ne pas se
retirer à temps et puis peut aussi
rester des spermatozoïdes planqué au
chaud dans l'urètre depuis une
éjaculation précédente et ils peuvent
être propulsé en cours de rapports par
le liquide pressé minal ça on le sent
pas nous donc on est sur une espèce de
roulette russe de la contraception et
même si on a mené
la vasectomie alors ça c'est un peu
comme la panse de brebis farcie
on sait que ça existe mais si on a le
choix on prend deux choses comment ça
marche
on bloque où on coupe tout simplement
les canaux déférents c'est à dire les
tuyaux par lesquels les spermatozoïdes
passe pour aller
des bourses jusqu'à l'urètre c'est très
efficace ça modifie pas la sexualité ni
même l'éjaculation juste et durable
c'est une forme de stérilisation c'est
un petit peu l'équivalent de la ligature
des trompes chez les femmes dans
l'absolu c'est pas forcément
irréversible mais l'opération pour
remettre les tuyaux boutabout elle est
assez compliqué et ça marche pas à tous
les coups donc il vaut mieux de bien
réfléchir avant
et dans tous les cas on peut congeler
son sperme avant notez qu'il ya
plusieurs solutions alternatives qui
consiste à injecter du gel dans les
canaux déférents soit pour bloquer les
spermatozoïdes soit pour les dégradés
mais tout ça c'est encore en phase de
test le slip chauffante
là on rentre dans les techniques un
petit peu expérimentale et on va tout de
suite casser un mythe
ça n'est pas un slip chauffage il n'y a
pas de dispositif qui produit de la
chaleur on n'est pas sur une cuisson des
roubignolles mais l'idée c'est quand
même de augmenter la température des
testicules parce que pour produire des
spermatozoïdes
ils ont besoin d'être au frais c'est
pour ça qu'à l'état sauvage ils sont à
l'extérieur
du coup la lidc par différents moyens
parce qu'il ya différents modèles de
flip soin de remonter les testicules
soin de les maintenir suffisamment près
du corps pour qu'ils soient bien au
chaud et qui produisent moins de petites
et armani l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
moins d'un millions de spermatozoïdes
par millilitre de sperme c'est à dire
100 fois moins que d'habitude à peu près
parce que c'est le seuil à partir duquel
on estime que la contraception est
efficace la contrainte c'est qu'il faut
le porter quinze heures par jour même
s'il n'ya pas eu d'étude de grande
ampleur a priori c'est efficace et c'est
réversible c'est à dire que ça rend pas
stérile
par contre c'est un petit peu compliqué
de s'en procurer dans le commerce
les injections d'hormones c'est une
technique qui développé depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années ça consiste à se faire
soi même
toutes les semaines une injection
d'hormones qui bloque la fabrication des
spermatozoïdes
c'est un peu long à démarrer en général
c'est efficace au bout
à moi d'injection mais ça marche très
bien et c'est réversible
par contre c'est un euphémisme de dire
que c'est très peu utilisé notamment
parce que ça n'est jamais proposé aux
hommes le gel dans la série
contraception hormonale ya aussi un gel
qu'on s'applique sur la peau tous les
jours et qui contient des hormones qui
font baisser le nombre de spermatozoïdes
là encore c'est en cours de
développement c'est à dire qu'il ya des
études qui sont menées actuellement mais
le produit a pas encore été mis sur le
marché
la pilule masculine le meilleur pour la
fin le avatar 2 de la contraception
masculine
ça fait des années qu'on en parle elle
est en phase de test les derniers
résultats sont hyper encourageant elle
est efficace des peu d'effets
secondaires mais elle n'a pas encore
reçu l'autorisation de commercialiser
alors pour être très clair
dans l'état actuel des choses pour la
pilule comme pour les autres moyens de
contraception hormonale masculine les
effets secondaires sont à peu près les
mêmes que ceux des pilules féminine du
coup en plus du processus d'autorisation
de mise en vente des nouveaux
traitements qui est très long c'est vrai
il ya un autre truc qui freine c'est
cette vieille idée selon laquelle c'est
normal que le poids de la responsabilité
de la contraception et des inconvénients
qui vont avec repose sur les femmes
alors petit truc factuel à ce sujet
aucun moyen de contraception mais
efficace à 100% par contre on peut en
utiliser plusieurs donc si chaque
partenaire fait sa part du boulot en
plus d'être plus équitable en plus
d'être plus responsables
individuellement en plus de donner à
l'homme le pouvoir de maîtriser aussi sa
propre fertilité et basse et plus
efficace et puis attention évidemment la
contraception qu'elle soit masculine ou
féminine elle protège pas contre les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
le seul moyen de se protéger c'est le
préservatif masculin ou féminin